This question is about Galileo and his experiments on motion.
Now, Galileo loved doing these experiments,
which is why is has this wonderful giant smile.
But Galileo didn't have stopwatch.
Instead, he measured time with a water clock.
A water clock was basically just a giant reservoir of water that he kept filled to the top
and that reservoir would leak at a constant rate.
By measuring the mass of water he collected in a certain time interval,
Galileo could infer how long an object had been moving, let's say rolling or dropping.
Let's define something called a time interval
and let's say that 1 time interval is the amount of time it takes
to fill up this bucket with one gram of water.
Let's say that when Galileo rolls this ball, he finds that in the first time interval
in which it's rolling, the ball rolls 0.8 m.
Maybe that means it rolled from here to here.
What I want you to tell me is how far the ball rolls in the second time interval and in the third.
Now, keep in mind I'm not asking how far it's rolled after two time intervals.
That would be the sum of the first distance and the second time interval distance.
I just want to know in the second time interval it rolls from, let's say,
here to some point on this board or on this plane.
I want you to tell me how big is this distance in the second time interval and in the third.
You can enter your answer here and here in meters.